so the first thing that we have here is
we have two endpoints of this segment
okay one two and five four and what we
want to do is we want to find the line
that's perpendicular so at a right angle
and it bisects it meaning it cuts it in
half so the first thing what we're going
to do is we're going to find that
midpoint that point halfway in between
the two endpoints so let's go ahead and
use our midpoint formula here notice
it's an average of the x-coordinates and
an average of the y-coordinates so let's
go ahead and write that down so we've
got the midpoint equals one plus five
divided by two and two plus four divided
by two so if we simplify that that's six
divided by two which is three 2 plus 4
is 6 divided by 2 which is also 3 so 3
comma 3 is our midpoint so let's go
ahead and mark that on our diagram so 3
3 right here okay so now what we're
going to do is we're going to find the
slope of this original line segment here
and so we're gonna use our slope formula
we're gonna take the y coordinate of
point 2 - the y coordinate of point 1
divided by the x coordinate of point 2
minus the x coordinate of point 1 so
let's go ahead and do that so we've got
4 minus 2 divided by 5 minus 1 okay so
we can see that's coming out to 2 over 4
which equals 1/2 so that means that this
is rising 1 running 2 rising one running
2 but if we want to find the slope of
the perpendicular line we need to take
the opposite reciprocal so opposite
means if we're gonna do the opposite of
positive 1/2 that's going to be negative
ok and then the reciprocal means we
could flip this over which is going to
be 2 over 1 or you could just say that's
equal to negative 2 okay so now what we
want to do is we want to write the
equation of this line but we've got the
point that the line goes through that's
3 3 and we've got the slope which is
negative 2 so let's go ahead and put
that together using our slope intercept
form of the line we're gonna use the y
equals MX plus B so let's write down
what we know so far so we have y equals
MX plus B the slope is negative 2
and the B value we don't actually know
that's the y-intercept that's where this
is crossing the y-axis but because we
have this point we can put the
x-coordinate in for x and the y
coordinate in for y and we can solve for
B so let's go ahead and do that so 3
equals negative 2 times 3 which is
negative 6 right plus B
add the six to both sides and you can
see that B is equal to nine so if we put
nine back in here we get y equals
negative 2x plus 9 now let's go ahead
and just see if we can graph it real
quick so through this point it's going
to have a slope of negative two so we're
going to go down two over one and if we
were to graph this it's going off the
board there but you can see it's going
to cross the y-axis way up here at
positive nine so I hope that helps you
understand how to work with the equation
of a perpendicular bisector subscribe to
the channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon